You and was a great believer in the dream
and I noted that dreams will tell you
things that you don't know.
And then I thought,
well,
how the hell can that be?
How would that in the world can something
you think up tell you something you
don't know?
How does that make any sense?
First of all,
why don't you understand it?
Why does it have to come forth
in the form of the dream?
It's like you're not,
there's something going on inside
you that you don't control rights.
The dream happens to you just
like life happens to you.
I mean there is the odd
lucid dreamer who can,
you know,
apply a certain amount
of conscious control,
but most of the time it's,
you're laying there asleep and this
crazy complicated world manifests itself
inside you and you don't
know how you could,
you can't do it when you're awake
and you don't know what it means.
It's like what the hell is going on?
And that's one of the things that's so
damn frightening about the psychoanalysts
because you get this both
from Freud and young,
you really start to understand that
there are things inside you that are
happening that control you
instead of the other way around.
You know,
he,
there's a bit of reciprocal control,
but there's manifestations of spirits so
to speak inside you that determine the
manner in which you walk through
life and you don't control it.
And what does,
is it random?
You know,
there are people who have claimed the
dreams are mirror merely the consequence
of random neuronal firing,
which is a theory I think is absolutely
absurd because there's nothing random
about dreams.
You know,
there are very,
very structured and very,
very complex and they're not like
snow on a television screen or,
or static on a radio.
Like those things are complicated.
And then also I've seen so often that
people have very coherent dreams that have
a perfect narrative structure.
Now they're fully developed,
did some sense.
And so that just as an ide,
that theory just doesn't
go anywhere with me.
I just can't see that as useful at all.
And so,
so I'm more likely to take
the phenomena seriously.
Say,
well,
there's something to dreams,
what you dream of the future.
And then you try to make it into a reality
that seems to be an important thing,
you know?
Or maybe you dream up at nightmare and
try to make that into a reality because
people do that too.
If they're hell bent on revenge,
for example,
and full of hatred and resentment
mean that manifest itself in terrible
fantasies,
you know,
those are dreams,
then people go act them out.
These things are powerful,
you know?
And whole nations can get
caught up in collective dreams.
That's what happened to the Nazis.
That's what happened to Nazi Germany
in the 1930s and it was absolutely
remarkable,
amazing,
horrific,
destructive spectacle.
And the same thing happened
in the Soviet Union.
The same thing happened in China.
It's like we have to take
these things seriously,
you know,
and try to understand what's going on.